saoudite. Le chemin qu'il a
emprunté pour se rendre ici
est un symbole fort.
Il est devenu le premieraiaiaiae
un vol direct de Tel Aviv à
Jeddah; les avions israéliens
seront désormais admis
dans l'espace aériplplplplplplpa
normalisation des relations
entre les deux pays.
"C'est une journée historique",
déclare le premier ministre
Les Américains aimeraient que
l'Arabie saoudite,
d'autres pays arabes l'ont fait
ces dernières années,
l'État hébreu; ils aimeraient
surtout quSaSaSaSaoudiens
augmentent leur production
de pétrole pour faire diminuer
Même si, pour y arriver,
il fndndndndre la main
au prince héritier
Mohammed ben Salmane.
apologize to his family, sir?
- Un rapport du renseignement
américain a conclu qu'il a
journaliste saoudien
Jamal Khashoggi. Joe Biden dit
lui en avoir parlé; il a répondu
responsable.
Et le sort d'une autrelilililil,
cette fois dans les territoi
palestiniens qu'il a visités
plus tôt. Shireen Abu Akleh,
aussi Américaine de surcroît,
a été tuée en mai pairiririr
israélien, alors qu'elle
couvrait une opération
"Sa mort, dit-il, est une perte
énorme pour le peuplepepepepepex
importante."
D'anciens collègues ont placé
son portrait sur une chaise,
bien en évidenceamamamamamamamat
de faire la lumière sur
ce qui lui est arrivée."Il fauts
responsables, indique le
président de l'Autorité
palestienne, le contraire
et au désespoir."
Il dit néanmoins tendre
la main à Israël.
Les conditions pour relancer
le processus de paix ne sont pas
réunies croit Joe Biden, mais il
promet de ne pas
Le président américain ne l'a
l'objectif de ce voyage était
de rerererer ses relations
avec ses deux principaux alliés
au Moyen-Orient. Il n'a jamais
avec l'Arabie saoudite,t-t-t-t-t
les réorienter
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,ngngno